bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat jeudi soir les
sénateurs ont adopté définitivement la
réforme des laboratoires de biologie
médicale
un secteur qui n'a connu aucune réforme
depuis 1975
malgré les fortes évolutions et qu'il a
pu connaître alors ce texte a pour
ambition d'empêcher la mainmise des
fonds d'investissements sur les
laboratoires de biologie médicale en
écartant notamment bien les
privatisations ou encore la
financiarisation de ce secteur
les sénateurs communistes ont voté
contre ce texte estimant qu'il aurait
hélas peu d'influx ans alors sans plus
tarder direction l'hémicycle du sénat
pour revenir sur cette séance bonne
matinée à tous l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion de la proposition
de loi portant réforme de la biologie
médicale dans la discussion générale la
parole et à monsieur jacky le menn
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
vous avez la parole chers collègues
madame la madame la présidente
la ministre madame la présidente par
intérim de la commission des affaires
sociales se précisent qu'à un point pour
les susceptibilités
mes chers collègues pas très nombreux
nous avons un concentré de qualité il
faut du nombre
la commission mixte paritaire réunie le
10 avril dernier pour trouver un texte
commun sur les dispositions restant en
discussion de la proposition de loi
relative à la biologie médicale
travailler dans un esprit constructif
est parvenu sans grande difficulté un
accord notre article rester en
discussion
lui qui ont été adoptées dans la
rédaction d'assemblée nationale et un
dans la rédaction du sénat il convient
de souligner que les solutions trouvées
par l'assemblée nationale ces articles
sont proches de celles qui avaient
choisi la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat et il y avait une
grande communauté de vues entre les
majorités de nous deux assemblées
sera-t-il capable la commission mixte
paritaire a précisé le champ de la
dérogation accordée aux laboratoires
établissement français du sang en
matière d'implantation géographique ce
souci rejoint celui de notre commission
de limiter les risques de distorsions de
concurrence avec les laboratoires
publics et privés effectuons les mêmes
examens tout en tenant compte de la
spécificité de la ffs ceci nous avaient
conduits en séance à adopter un demande
du gouvernement une dérogation général
pour les laboratoires de cet
établissement
la cmp a par ailleurs limité aux seuls
prélèvements les étapes d'un examen qui
sera possible de conduire hors d'un
laboratoire de biologie médicale
nous avions pour notre part élargi cette
possibilité à l'ensemble de la phase pré
analytique considérant qu'il n'était pas
possible de séparer juridiquement l'acte
de prêt le mas des autres composantes de
cette phase d'étiquetage conditionnement
transport etc
cette formulation suscitait pourtant
être mais reconnaît des inquiétudes
parmi les acteurs il convient de les
prendre en compte
c'est ce qui a été fait cmt
a rétabli l'article 6 ans que j'étais
personnellement d'ailleurs très attachés
qui ouvre la possibilité à certains
médecins non titulaires du drs de
biologie médicale d'accéder à des postes
de praticiens hospitaliers
je rappelle que le sénat s'était opposé
à plusieurs reprises à cette mesure
la biologie médicale est néanmoins une
discipline spéciale mixte parce qu'elle
peut être exercée par des pharmaciens et
par des médecins et réunissant plusieurs
disciplines différentes notamment la
génétique sans doute le statut la
génétique au sein des chu de nantes il à
être précisé s'il était reconnu comme
spécialité à part entière cela
permettrait sans doute de mettre fin à
plusieurs demandes d'octroi de postes de
pays ou de biologie médicale
en l'état actuel rédaction de l'article
6 me paraît tout à fait équilibré et
constitue un compromis lacement acceptée
par les acteurs à l'article 6 i l
article 7 la cmp a rétabli des mesures
transitoires permettant aux praticiens
et ans et c'est la biologie médicale
pendant plusieurs années avant l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi de continuer cet
exercice surtout à ce que c'est la cmp a
rétabli les paliers d'accréditation qui
avait envisagé une autre commission des
affaires sociales en prévoyant un seuil
de 50% 2016 70 % 2018 et 100 % en 2020
ne sont pas soumis à l'accréditation des
examens et 9 ans qui figure parmi les
actes en nommant créatures et qui ne
sont pas encore évalués par la haute
autorité de santé
j'ai indiqué à plusieurs reprises au
cours de nos débats pourquoi il est
essentiel de fixer un objectif à 100%
sans lequel l'accréditation perd son
fondement
en effet comme l'a souligné fort
justement à l'assemblée nationale
ségolène neuville rapporteur de cette
ppl
comment choisir des examens qui ne
nécessiterait pas d'accréditation
s'agit-il d'examen moins importants -
diront utiles que d'autres examens
mais si on abonde dans ce sens il est
bien évident que on se demanderait que
légitimité de ces examens
chaque laboratoire peut choisir les
types d'examens au clip recettes et
personne ne l'obligent à se faire
accréditer surtout les examens existants
à 100% mais sur les examens que le
laboratoire exercent
il est impératif pour la sécurité des
patients qu'ils soient progressivement
accrédités à 100% donc il ya vu un
message dans cet objectif
certains ont craint que l'accréditation
n'empêche l'innovation ou et se
comprendre
il me semble que la rédaction de
l'assemblée nationale adopté par la cmp
limite cette crainte je précise
toutefois qu'il ne s'agit pas d'exonérer
de l'accréditation tous les actes hors
nomenclature mais seulement parmi eux la
minorité qui s'est considéré comme
innovante
c'est à dire dont l'efficacité n'est pas
encore établi un article 7 bis sur les
examens urgents la commission miss paris
a prévu la fixation pas arrêté de la
liste des examens concernés sur
l'article 8 relatif aux formes
d'exercice de détention du capital des
laboratoires
la cmp a prévu à transmission aux orres
compétents de l'ensemble des contrats
est rétabli disposition qui avait été
introduite au sénat contre l'avis de la
commission relativement à la détention
minoritaire du capital
ces dispositions font l'objet d'un
amendement du gouvernement
nous y reviendrons sur les articles 9 et
cmp a procédé à des améliorations
rédactionnelles elle a supprimé
l'article 10 bis relatif à l'encadrement
des tarifs du cofrac au bénéfice de
l'anc est demandé sur ma proposition
d'ailleurs par la commission des
affaires sociales à la cour des comptes
messieurs affaires sociales du sénat
enfin elle a complété l'article 11 ans
prévoyant un régime adapté au territoire
de la guadeloupe de la guyane de la
martinique et mayotte
le texte sur lequel nous avons abouti me
paraît parfaitement équilibré et sous
réserve de l'amendement du gouvernement
juridiquement solide tout surtout sur
ses bords nous partageons la volonté de
garantir la place de la biologie
médicale comme profession mais
ical et n'ont qu'une profession
commerciale ce texte comporte des
dispositions de nature à limiter la
financiarisation de la profession et à
garantir la possibilité pour les jeunes
biologistes d'exercer leur métier en
toute indépendance
mais je tiens à rappeler que la biologie
médicale s'exerce majoritairement à
titre libéral et qu'à ce titre des
entraves que nous pouvons porter la
liberté de la concurrence doivent être
limités ce que j'ai appelé plusieurs
fois d'ailleurs dans les interventions
en commission des affaires sociales ou
dans la musique ça cela l'application du
droit européen est susceptible de priver
les praticiens de toute protection face
aux intérêts financiers
l'amendement présenté par là le
gouvernement est nécessaire pour
garantir la sécurité juridique de
l'ensemble des mesures prises par pour
garantir l'indépendance des jeunes
biologistes du reste d'ailleurs cet
amendement qui a été sous liste de midi
en début d'après midi à la commission
des affaires sociales a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat
ce ne sont pas seulement les
laboratoires privés qui sont visés par
ce texte
la biologie médicale publique est
pleinement engagé dans la réforme de la
profession et dans le processus
d'accréditation
nous n'avons pas et c'est un point
essentiel créer de distinction entre le
niveau de qualité que les usagers sont
en droit de 30 du public et du privé par
l'accréditation le plus haut niveau de
qualité sera garantie à tous sur
l'ensemble du territoire
si nous adoptons ce soir définitivement
la proposition de loi que j'ai déposé
plusieurs membres du groupe socialiste
sera l'aboutissement d'un travail de
plusieurs années porté par de nombreuses
personnes dont plusieurs nos collègues
membres de l'ancienne majorité
certains ne siège plus au sein de notre
assemblée mais tous je tiens à saluer
comme d'autres avant moi j'ai essayé
sans a priori d'entendre et si possible
de réunir l'ensemble des nombreuses
parties prenantes du secteur de la
biologie médicale sans jamais
interrompre le dialogue trouver un texte
parfaitement consensuelle ces arrêts
avéré impossible mais je pense que celui
qui vous est proposée ce soir à mende et
par là le gouvernement sera le moyen
parfait possible
je m'en réjouis pour la biologie
dicale pour c'est pas ce praticien pour
ces patients surtout et pour l'avenir de
l'organisation et soit notre pays je
profite pour remercier les
administrateurs nos collaborateurs des
deux assemblées pour l'excellent travail
effectué en relation avec le ministère
de la santé et vous madame la ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est à
huy a parlé d'un marisol touraine mise
affaires sociales et de la santé
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales je me garderai bien de
caractériser votre titre monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs au
terme de cette lecture vous serez amené
à vous prononcer sur une proposition de
loi qui a l'ambition de porter la
biologie médicale française de demain
plus de 40 où près de 40 années se sont
en effet écoulés sans que une réforme
majeure ou des évolutions significatives
soit intervenu permettant à ce secteur
de relever le double défi auquel il est
aujourd'hui confronté celui de la
qualité et celui de l'efficience la
proposition de loi issue de votre
travail que je vous appelle soutenir est
un aboutissement un longue aboutissement
d'ailleurs elle est le fruit d'un
travail parlementaire constructif qui a
permis de faire se rejoindre des
positions au départ différentes même si
elle n'était pas nécessairement
divergentes
ce texte a été déposé par les membres du
groupe socialiste du sénat et de
l'assemblée
et je tiens à cet égard a salué
l'engagement et le travail de votre
rapporteur jacky le menn ainsi que celui
de la rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale
ségolène neuville qui ont pleinement
contribué à son élaboration
les échanges qui ont eu lieu au cours de
l'examen de ce texte ainsi que les
amendements qui ont été déposés ont
permis d'avancer les travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire en réunissant
les représentants des deux assemblées
des deux chambres ont permis de forger
une position commune et de consolider un
équilibre qui permet de renforcer les
principes et les ambitions d'une réforme
majeure majeur parce qu'elle permettra
d'apporter des garanties nouvelles aux
patients la première exigence en effet
de cette proposition de loi est
d'assurer la qualité des examens en
biologie mais dit
elle nous savons tous ici la place
centrale des biologistes médicaux dans
la prise en charge des patients ils sont
au coeur de l'organisation de notre
système de santé ça n'est pas à
l'organisation du système de soins et à
côté la biologie médicale c'est une
organisation commune globale et le
travail des biologistes et déterminant
pour assurer la qualité des soins et
c'est tout le sens de la démarche de
l'accréditation qui résultera de ce
texte de loi
elle sera la garantie donnée aux
patients de la fiabilité des résultats
partout sur le territoire
c'est pour cela que notre objectif
absolument impératif et que d'ici 2020
100 % des examens soit accrédités il y
va de la qualité de la prise en charge
des patients vous avez par ailleurs
souhaité dans la commission mixte
paritaire préserver l'article 6 de ce
texte et je m'en réjouis
ces dispositions vont permettre d'ouvrir
à des médecins et des pharmaciens
recruté en centre hospitalier
universitaire l'exercice des fonctions
de biologiste médical alors même qu' ils
ne sont pas titulaires d'un diplôme de
spécialiste en biologie médicale
l'article 6 permettra ainsi à des
professionnels de santé de répondre aux
besoins de leur activité en exerçant
exclusivement dans leur champ de
compétence il était essentiel aux yeux
du gouvernement que cet article fut
rétablie et ce dans l'intérêt des
patients la seconde exigence qui doivent
guider la modernisation de la biologie
médicale et celle de l'efficience
nous devons permettre à ce secteur de
disposer des moyens de se structurer et
économiquement sans sombrer dans les
abus de la financiarisation et au fond
c'était bien là le point de départ de ce
texte de l'ambition commune partagée par
les membres des assemblées et du sénat
tout particulièrement la volonté de
d'éviter que la biologie médicale que le
secteur de la santé de façon plus
générale le sombre sous les fourches
caudines de la seule expression de la
recherche de rentabilité et l'article 8
de la proposition de loi est
l'expression de cette volonté et de
cette démarche
ces dispositions visent à assurer aux
biologistes médicaux
la maîtrise de leur instrument de
travail
ces dispositions autoriseront également
une mise en conformité progressive afin
de ne pas déstabiliser le secteur et
elles consolideront la transparence des
conventions et des contrats signés dans
le cadre des sociétés d'exercice libéral
c'est dans le cadre de l'examen de cet
article que la commission mixte
paritaire a souhaité introduire de
nouvelles dispositions qui se retrouvent
au alinéa 7 8 et 9 de cet article 8 qui
vise à fixer un seuil minimal de
détention du capital social pour chaque
biologiste médical exerçant au sein
d'une société d'exercice libéral
toutefois ce seuil minimal est
incompatible avec les exigences du droit
communautaire dans la mesure où ils
créeraient une restriction aux libertés
de circulation dont la liberté
d'établissement
mais surtout je dois dire il me semble
que il serait susceptible ce seuil des
20 c de l'exercice de la biologie
médicale des jeunes biologistes qui ne
disposerait pas des revenus ou du
capital suffisant pour pouvoir engager
leurs activités au seuil ainsi fixé et
donc il me paraissait il me paraît
nécessaire de ne pas maintenir cette
disposition dans le texte final et c'est
la raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
a souhaité déposer un amendement de
suppression de sept de ses alinéas qui a
été adoptée mardi dernier à l'assemblée
nationale monsieur le rapporteur vous
l'avez
indiqué qui a été examinée et adoptée à
l'occasion de votre de la réunion de
votre commission des affaires sociales
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs avec
cette lecture nous arrivons au terme de
la procédure parlementaire
je crois que c'est un beau travail qui a
été collectivement conduit qui
représente une avancée majeure pour le
secteur de la biologie médicale et qui
donc représentera une garantie une
protection pour nos concitoyens
je veux donc vous remercier chacune et
chacun individuellement pour la part que
vous avez prises à l'élaboration de ce
texte remercier le travail qui a été
conduit et mes remerciements vont
également bien sûr aux services de la
commission des affaires sociales et de
la séance qui ont perfé qui ont permis
un parfait déroulement de nos bébés
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole et à catherine de roche groupe
ump pour 12 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues le rapport ballereau de
septembre 2008 a tracé les grandes
lignes de l'ordonance de 2010 pour
renforcer le caractère médical de la
discipline de voix étaient envisageables
soit industrialisés la biologie médicale
en afin de réduire les coûts en partant
du principe que l'analyse médicale une
simple prestation technique soit
considérée de l'analyse est un acte
médical qui apporte une réponse à une
question clinique par un examen
approprié
c'était un envoi qui avait été
privilégié avec la réforme initiée en
2010 ce dont nous nous félicitons avec
cette ordonnance il s'agissait
d'atteindre plusieurs objectifs garantir
la qualité des actes et la confiance des
professionnels et des patients assurer
l'efficience des dépenses nécessité
économique et éthique et enfin assurer
une bonne adéquation entre nos exigences
nationales et celles de l'union
européenne la biologie médicale reste un
enjeu majeur des politiques publiques en
matière de santé et de maintien d'une
profession de qualité sur notre
territoire
cela a été rappelé lors de nos débats
sur tous les bancs nous sommes
convaincus de la nécessité de préserver
les spécificités de la biologie médicale
française aussi c'est pour réaffirmer le
caractère médical la profession
biologiste et permettre des évolutions
de structures en cohérence avec
l'évolution des connaissances
scientifiques et technologiques que le
précédent gouvernement avait souhaité
entreprendre une nouvelle réforme
avec cette ordonnance après le parcours
parlementaire pour le moins décousu de
cette réforme nous voici réunis pour
voter les conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire sur la proposition de
loi notre collègue et rapporteur jacky
le menn dont je tiens à saluer le
travail
ce texte a pour principal objectif l'art
est la ratification ordonnance de 2010
je rappelle que l'absence de
ratification crée une insécurité
juridique préjudiciable tant pour les
professionnels de santé que pour les
pouvoirs publics
le texte adopté par la commission mixte
paritaire reprend pour l'essentiel le
texte voté par l'assemblée nationale
je souhaite revenir sur les articles
qui nous sommes les plus importants
l'article 1er bis à firmin
médicalisation la biologie médicale dans
l'intérêt de la sécurité des patients et
prévoit la présence obligatoire d'un
biologiste par site
l'article 4 organise les conditions de
réalisation des prélèvements de biologie
médicale lors de l'examen de cet article
en première lecture nous avons rappelé
que la qualité de l'analyse du
prélèvement
jusqu'au résultat est plus facile à
garantir lorsque ce prélèvement est
effectué en laboratoire il est cependant
utile notamment pour des raisons de
proximité géographique des patients de
permettre aux infirmières ou aux
médecins de réaliser des prélèvements à
domicile la rédaction issue de travaux
ne nous semblait pas satisfaisante
en revanche celle adoptée par la cmp
correspond à ce que nous avions défendu
en première lecture à savoir restreindre
le champ de l'examen de biologie
médicale
en dehors du laboratoire de biologie
médicale au seul prélèvement des
échantillons biologiques
de cette manière le reste de la phase
pré analytique reste sous le contrôle du
biologiste l'article 5 concerne
l'interdiction des ristournes ce sujet
et déjà débattus à maintes reprises par
le parlement nous considérons que cette
pratique est contraire aux principes de
tarification des actes médicaux et le
retour aux ristournes est très mal vécu
par la profession qu'ils interprètent
comme une négation la médicalisation
dans la mesure où ils assimilent les
analyses biologiques et des prestations
de services cependant il existe un cas
pour lequel nous aurions dû prévoir une
dérogation permettant de prendre en
compte la spécificité de la situation de
certains hôpitaux nous parlons souvent
de l'importance du maillage territorial
mais dans certes mais certains
départements ne dispose pas de
laboratoires publics de biologie
médicale et leurs hôpitaux sont troupe
éloigné d'autres établissements équipés
d'un laboratoire
conformément à la réglementation les
établissements de santé publics doivent
traiter des laboratoires privés qui
consentent alors des rom us nous
regrettons de ne pas avoir été entendus
sur la difficulté que rencontrent ces
établissements publics de santé ne
disposant pas d'un laboratoire public
nous ne voulons pas faire perdurer les
ristournes manille
à mercantile mais vite et aux
établissements de santé la double peine
plus de laboratoires et davantage de
dépenses
l'article 6 doit permettre le
recrutement en chu et dans les
établissements qui leur sont liés par
convention soit de professeur des
universités praticien hospitalier soit
de maître de conférences des universités
praticien hospitalier non titulaires du
drs de biologie médicale
cette perspective créé en même temps
qu'elle décourage les étudiants en
biologie médicale d'envisager une
carrière hospitalière
un sentiment d'injustice et
dévalorisation de leur formation
le sénat a déjà rejeté en 2011 une
disposition analogue à laquelle
s'opposent l'ensemble la profession et
les ordres concernés il ne semble pas
qu'il y ait plus de raison d'accepter
aujourd'hui cette dérogation qu'il n'y
en avait en 2011 l'article 7 prévoit des
ajustements en matière d'exercice de la
biologie médicale et fixe les paliers
d'accréditation des laboratoires
l'accréditation à 100% été inséré par la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat puisque la limiter à 80 % à 90 %
ne satisfaisait pas un des objectifs
majeurs de la réforme à savoir la
qualité prouvé par l'accréditation
rendre obligatoire l'accréditation
laboratoire est la seule modalité
envisageable pour prouver la qualité des
examens de biologie médicale
ce sera ainsi la seule discipline
médicale dans laquelle existe une
accréditation le calendrier échelonné de
la mise en place d'une accréditation à
100 % au 1er novembre 2020 apparaît donc
raisonnable cependant nous sommes
conscients des difficultés de
laboratoire la tarification des actes
gelé depuis des années certains tarifs
ayant même été diminués d'autorité par
les pouvoirs publics
pris en étau entre une accréditation
relativement coûteuses et le gel de la
tarification leurs actes certains
laboratoires risque de se trouver en
difficulté un équilibre et donc à
trouver pour que certains d'entre eux en
particulier dans les territoires ruraux
puisse continuer d'exister
l'article 18 qui vise à freiner
financiarisation du secteur en
rétablissement en rétablissant le
principe d'une détention majoritaire du
capital de la société d'exercice libéral
par les biologistes a été largement
remanié par la cmp pour répondre
notamment l'inquiétude des jeunes
biologistes et de ceux qui veulent
préserver une biologie médicale de
proximité et non financiarisé le seul
accès des biologistes au capital
laboratoires n'étaient pas à lui seul
suffisant pour garantir leur
indépendance pour lutter efficacement
contre cette financiarisation et
promouvoir la transparence
il était nécessaire de prévoir un
mécanisme rendant obligatoire la
communication de l'ensemble des
conventions aux ordres compétents c'est
ce que la cmp a prévu et nous nous
réjouissons de cet apport en août nous
avions proposé fait adopté en première
lecture la suppression du statut
d'associé ultra minoritaire dans les
laboratoires de biologie médicale
je rappelle que la législation sur les
sociétés d'exercice libéral de
biologistes est détournée par certains
investisseurs qui ne propose qu'une
fraction infime des parts sociales aux
nouveaux entrants ou les dépossédant à
contractuellement du contrôle effectif
des partisans à keith dans certains cas
sur simple notification des
investisseurs financiers
le biologique doit céder ses parts à
l'acheteur désigné par ces derniers dans
les faits ce sont donc souvent les
investisseurs financiers qui contrôle la
part des biologistes dans le capital et
plus généralement l'intégralité du
capital des laboratoires dans lesquelles
ils ont investi
nous nous félicitions que le statut
d'associé au cra minoritaires été
supprimée par la cmp et nous retraitons
donc l'amendement de suppression des
alinéas 1 7 à 9 du gouvernement
l'article 9 renforce le rôle des agences
régionales de santé en leur permettant
de réguler l'offre de biologie médicale
sur les territoires cet article va donc
dans le sens du rapport ballereau qui
proposait de conserver le principe de
liberté d'installation et de mettre en
place une régulation
cet article protège ainsi la proximité
territoriale et sans empêcher les
restructurations nécessaires aux
laboratoires pour qu'ils atteignent
taille critique et puisse ainsi faire
face aux enjeux économiques et
techniques de l'avenir l'instabilité
actuelle est préjudiciable à l'avenir de
la profession dans le secteur
hospitalier et surtout dans le secteur
libéral il est nécessaire d'y mettre un
terme
certaines mesures de cette proposition
de loi ne nous satisfont pas totalement
toutefois comme nous soutenons le
pratiquer le principe de ce texte et
tenons à faire preuve d'une attitude
constructive nous n'empêcherons pas son
adoption
c'est pourquoi le groupe ump
s'abstiendra je vous remercie vous
n'exigez collègues
la parole est à madame laurence cohen du
groupe crc pour sept minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la réforme de la
biologie médicale n'aura pas été un long
fleuve tranquille
nous connaissons ce soir d'ailleurs un
nouveau rebondissement
quels sont les enjeux de ce projet il
s'agit de faire concilier deux
impératifs complémentaires assurer un
haut niveau de sécurité dans les
opérations de biologie médicale et
éviter que les groupes financiers dans
les seuls intérêts sont spéculatifs
s'accapare progressivement par après par
laboratoire après laboratoire du secteur
de la biologie médicale sur la sécurité
d'abord le gouvernement a fait le choix
de rendre progressivement obligatoire
une certification total que nous ne
contestons pas sur le principe
toutefois nous regrettons qu'il ait fait
le choix d'une structure qui par le
passé y compris récents s'est fait
connaître par ses défaillances plus
d'ailleurs que par ses qualités
nous aurions préféré quant à nous que
cette mission essentielle soient assumés
par une agence publique
quant à la financiarisation de la
biologie médicale nous sommes contraints
de constater que les mesures retenues
dans ce projet de loi ne parviendront ni
à la freiner comme le souhaitait notre
collègue qui le mène ni à y mettre un
terme comme le groupe crc l'espérait en
effet la rédaction de l'article 8 tel
qu'issu des travaux des deux assemblées
de la cmp continue à créer une confusion
entre les biologistes exerçant et ce
temps et ce en exercice seuls ces
derniers peuvent détenir plus de la
moitié de parts sociales d'une selle
de biologie médicale hors la loi
française y compris cet article 8 et les
règles européennes précise que les
personnes morales peuvent être
considérés comme des biologistes en
exercice et ce même si ces personnes
morales sont à 100% des groupes
financiers
ce que j'ai décrit là mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas un fantasme du
groupe crc
c'est une réalité une holding financière
détenue par des fonds de pension possède
déjà en france la totalité des parts
sociales de 130 laboratoires de biologie
médicale
cela est rendu possible par la loi
murcef qui résident des sociétés
d'exercice de toutes les professions
libérales dont la biologie et qui
n'organisent pas la distinction entre
les personnes physiques et morales nous
avions pour notre part déposé un
amendement prévoyant que 51 % du capital
au moins soit détenu par un biologiste
personnes physiques seraient ceux qui
auraient permis de contourner ce risque
hélas ça n'a pas été adopté et donc
l'article 8 dans sa rédaction actuelle
n'empêchera pas demain les groupes
financiers
les fonds d'investissement et les fonds
de pension de tête de détenir 100% des
parts d'une selle de biologie médicale
qui plus est aussi peu efficace que soit
cet article 8
il ne serait applicable qu'aux
laboratoires constitué après l'adoption
de cette loi
autrement dit les groupes financiers
peuvent sans entraves d'aucune sorte
s'approprier les quatre villes
laboratoires existants à ce jour on nous
rétorque que les laboratoires de
biologie médicale doivent obéir aux
mêmes règles que celles imposées à
toutes les sociétés d'exercice
à ceci près que les laboratoires de
biologie médicale contenu des missions
qui sont les leurs ne peuvent pas être
assimilés à des entreprises marchandes
comme les autres afin de mettre un terme
à cette marchandisation de la santé
il aurait fallu profiter de l'occasion
pour créer un nouveau statut juridique
plus protecteur pour les patients et les
biologistes qui interdisent enfin aux
sociétés financières de vente elysées la
biologie médicale
enfin concernant l'amendement déposé par
le gouvernement celui ci ne nous
apparaît pas pertinent et je veux m'en
expliquer tout d'abord l'objet de cet
amendement précise je cite il ferait
également peser une menace sur le
devenir des sociétés dans lesquelles les
biologistes exerçant ne détenant pas la
fraction minimale requise ne serait pas
en capacité d'acquérir des
participations supplémentaires
or la rédaction de l'article 8 tel
qu'issu de la cmp prévoit que c'est à
titre prioritaire et non exclusif les
mots ont leur importance que les parts
sociales sont proposées aux jeunes
biologistes si ces derniers ne peuvent
pas les acquérir
alors d'autre que les exerçant pourront
se porter acquéreur il n'y alors rien de
scandaleux à prévoir une sanction en cas
de non respect d'une procédure qui donne
la priorité à des personnes physiques
sur des groupes financiers en août vous
préciser que certains biologistes
pourrait ne pas disposer des ressources
leur permettant d'acquérir les parts
sociales
cela est effectivement vrai mais plutôt
que de supprimer cette disposition qui
est la seule de nature à protéger les
jeunes biologistes du statut d'associé
ultra minoritaire pourquoi ne pas
proposer un mécanisme leur permettant
d'acquérir c'est pas cela s'est déjà
fait je pense par exemple aux
assistantes maternelles en vue de leur
installation
si l'on refuse que la santé soit une
marchandise si l'on veut faire obstacle
à la financiarisation
si l'on veut que les laboratoires de
biologie médicale puissent rester des
acteurs de santé de proximité qui joue
un rôle majeur dans le maillage
territorial
c'est une mesure comme celle ci qu'il
aurait fallu prendre enfin vous préciser
dans l'objet de cet amendement que le
dispositif est de nature à créer des
entraves à ses libertés qui ne peuvent
être directement justifiée par des
objectifs de santé publique
seuls susceptibles d'être invoquée
auprès des instances communautaires
nous ne partageons pas votre excès de
prudence vous dites que ces deux alinéas
sont non conformes au droit
communautaire tout en précisant un peu
plus haut dans l'objet de votre
amendement qu'ils sont de toute façon
inutile puisque les alinéas 1 à 6
permettent d'arriver à la même situation
que les deux années à que vous proposez
de supprimer c'est à dire à garantir le
fait que la majorité du capital soit
détenu par des biologistes en exercice
autrement dit selon vous à des personnes
physiques
mais alors si l'exercice si l'article 8
permet même sens les alinéas que vous
proposez de supprimer de parvenir à
cette situation
c'est tout l'art ti
8 qui est contraire au droit européen et
non pas seulement les alinéas 7 à 9
il ya une véritable contradiction donc
pour conclure si l'europe sanctionne au
titre de la libre circulation des
capitaux
c'est à dire au titre de la libre
concurrence et de la loi des marchés les
pays qui tentent à raison de protéger
certains acteurs des appétits et des
dangers de la finance c'est qu'il y a
urgence madame la ministre à changer
d'europe plutôt que de s'y soumettre
pour toutes ces raisons et au regard des
évolutions récentes de ce projet de loi
et la façon dont elle se présente ce
soir à nos yeux
le groupe crc votera contre ce projet
merci madame cohen la parole est à jean
pierre plancade du groupe rdse pour six
minutes
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la présidente la
commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues depuis le rapport
ballereau de 2008 qui préconisait la
réforme de la biologie médicale
celle ci aura connu bien des
vicissitudes le recours aux eaux denses
par le précédent gouvernement que nous
avions dénoncée lors de l'examen de la
loi hpst surtout les vents d'ailleurs de
l'opposition de l'époque
loin de permettre une application rapide
de la réforme a surtout contribué à une
insécurité juridique tentative
d'abrogation de l'ordonance de 2010
censure de la ppl fourcade par le
conseil constitutionnel ou encore
caducité du dernier texte adopté par
l'assemblée nationale
aucun de nos débats n'aura abouti à
concrétiser ce qui était pourtant
attendue par la profession à savoir la
médicalisation de la discipline et le
refus et le refus de sa financiarisation
je leur dis parce que ça avait été
exprimé d'ailleurs sur beaucoup de bas
et notamment sur l'opposition de
l'époque à laquelle j'appartenais la
proposition de leurs collègues jacky le
menn veut mettre un terme à ces
tribulations ratifié en ordonnance 2010
tout en introduisant les modifications
sur certains points des modifications
cet emprunt son mérite est d'offrir un
cadre d'exercices tu as enfin stabilisée
aux biologistes médicaux
est ce à dire que ce cadre est
satisfaisant je crains de rendre un peu
le consensus qui semble se dégager à
l'exception de mes collègues du crc de
rob lowe consensus donc autour du texte
issu de la cmp qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui certains points sont
positifs il faut bien le reconnaître
nous le reconnaissons volontiers je
pense notamment à la dérogation accordée
au laboratoire de l'établissement
français du sang en matière
d'implantation géographique la rédaction
retenue par la cmp semble répondre de
manière satisfaisante au souci du sénat
de limiter les risques de distorsion de
concurrence tout en tenant compte de la
spécificité de la ffs bien entendu il
nous faudra être vigilant sur
l'application concrète de cette
dérogation
je pense également aux conditions de
réalisation des examens de biologie
médicale
mon collègue gilbert barbier s'était
battu pour limiter au seul prélèvement
et non à toute la phase pré navy
dit comme cela était finalement voté par
le sénat le champ de l'examen réalisable
or dans le laboratoire confier
l'intégralité de cette phase à des
professionnels qui n'ont pas été formés
à cet effet pourrait non seulement un
problème en termes de responsabilité
voire de qualité me rené sur toi ou tes
aux biologistes une partie fondamentale
de ses fonctions notamment le recueil
des éléments techniques pertinentes et
la préparation des échantillons
le texte de la cmp est en phase avec nos
propositions et avec la volonté de
médicaliser la biologie médicale
je pense également à l'interdiction des
ristournes dont leur tour adopté dans la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2012 avait été très mal
vécu par la profession
cela revenait en effet assimile les
analyses biologiques à de simples
prestations de services je pense enfin
aux mesures qui visent à renforcer
l'indépendance professionnelle en
rétablissant des règles de majorité au
capital et de droits sociaux pour les
biologistes exerçant et le tout en
imposant la communication aux ors de
l'ensemble des conventions signés dans
le cadre des scènes malgré ces points
positifs nous demeurons très réservé
chacun mesure la place de plus en plus
importante de la biologie médicale dans
le parcours de soins l'évolution des
techniques la multiplication des normes
contre un laboratoire à de gros
investissements dans l'immobilier le
matériel la logistique de nouvelles
compétences au prix d'un regroupement
des structures
la réforme proposée par leur danse a
accentué ce phénomène et nous nous
doutons que les quelques ajustements de
cette proposition de loi soit suffisant
à les freiner
le risque c'est de transformer nos
laboratoires de proximité en zone rurale
qui sont à l'écouté du patient et des
professionnels de santé en de simples
centres de prélèvement ou boîtes aux
lettres ou pire de les voir disparaître
ce qui ad ailleurs dans certaines
régions et départements où commencer
l'accréditation obligatoire décidée en
2010 et renforcé aujourd'hui par
l'instauration d'un taux de 100 % de
l'activité de laboratoire en 2020 a
achevé de mettre sous pression la
profession qui a suivi par ailleurs une
longue série de baisses de tarifs nous
sommes évidemment attachés à la sécurité
sanitaire et au renforcement de la
qualité mais nous continuons de penser
qu une accréditation à marche forcée
même si j'admets que le texte issu de la
cmp à cordes des délais et prévoit des
paliers mais nous pensons qu'ils vont
renforcer le risque de financière
édition de ce secteur
devant le coût qu'elle représente un
grand nombre de petits laboratoires
indépendants et de proximité seront dans
l'obligation de renoncer
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les plus anciens
cela de vendre et les plus jeunes
hésitent à rejoindre la profession vous
allez dire c'est du pain béni dans cette
république même si le mot est un peu
malheureux pour les grands groupes
financiers qui ont déjà à la manoeuvre
qui sont déjà à la manoeuvre pour faire
de la biologie médicale comme
malheureusement d'autres secteurs la
santé un marché excusez moi le mot un
marché juteux et sans risque
et surtout sans risque puisqu'il est une
fille née solvabiliser par l'assurance
maladie
nul doute que ces opérateurs arriveront
toujours à contourner les quelques
dispositions de cette proposition de loi
nous regrettons la suppression de
l'article 10 bis qui encadraient les
tarifs du coc farc du cofrac organisme
indépendant chargé de l'accréditation
notre rapporteur dont je tiens ici à
saluer le travail le sérieux à proposer
de faire figurer ce texte parmi les
enquêtes sollicité auprès la cour des
comptes
nous soutenons pleinement cette démarche
et cette proposition que dire aussi du
sort réservé à nos amendements en faveur
des jeunes biologistes
à notre grande satisfaction d'un super
introduit à l'article reid le principe
d'une participation minimale pour les
jeunes biologistes associés adopté au
sénat à l'initiative de notre collègue
gilbert barbier notamment est écarté
ensuite par l'assemblée nationale le
statut d'associé ultra-minoritaire place
en effet les jeunes biologistes dans une
situation précaire les rendant
licenciables à merci sa suppression ne
prête pas une solution sans inconvénient
mais parce qu'il faudra bien trouver un
moyen d'assurer la transmission
intergénérationnelle
mais je ne vois pas cet effort de
réflexion dans l'amendement déposé dans
déposé par le gouvernement
nous avons essayé de le comprendre de
lire sous tous ses angles
enfin nous déplorons vivement la
réintroduction de l'article 6 qui avait
été supprimée par le sénat
il y à quelques paradoxes à prévoir un
diplôme d'études spécialisées de
biologie
et à considérer que celui ci n'est pas
forcément nécessaire pour obtenir un
potentiel chez nous persistons à penser
qu'il n'y a pas de raison objective à
créer une nouvelle voie dérogatoire
alors que l' ordonnance en prévoyait
déjà plusieurs madame la ministre mes
chers collègues nos débats ont été
riches et très instructif mais ils n'ont
pas abouti à un texte totalement
satisfaisante malgré de bonnes
intentions
nous sommes convaincus qu'il n'atteindra
pas son objectif affiché d'empêcher la
disparition de laboratoire indépendant
et de proximité est au contraire le
risque grande d'une concentration de
l'activité de laboratoire sur des
plateaux techniques toujours plus
éloignés des territoires ruraux
je ne suis pas convaincu qu'il lève
l'amertume de toute une profession qui
s'est manifestée récemment par des
fermetures de laboratoire sur tout le
territoire
c'est pourquoi l'ensemble des membres du
groupe du rdse à l'unanimité pour une
fois s'opposera aux textes issus des
conclusions de la cmp
en même temps que l'amendement du
gouvernement merci chers collègues
la parole est à aline archimbaud groupes
écologistes pour six minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues nous voilà au
terme d'un parcours long et sinueux
plusieurs l'ont rappelé avant moi
puisque ce texte sur la biologie
médicale et le cinquième sur ce thème
avoir été inscrit à l'ordre du jour du
sénat
en quatre ans et le sujet suscite un
débat encore assez animée nous avons pu
le constater tous
mais grâce aux efforts de notre
rapporteur pour susciter la concertation
grâce au travail constructif des
collègues de la commission des affaires
sociales nous avons pu parvenir à un
texte que nous jugeons équilibrer notre
groupe s'en réjouit et vous remercie
chers collègues pour le juste compromis
entre qualité accessibilité proximité et
indépendance de la biologie médicale
auquel nous arrivons aujourd'hui en lien
avec les deux problématiques
fondamentales que sont l'accréditation
et la lutte contre la financiarisation
l'accréditation tout d'abord c'est il
faut bien le reconnaître
difficile à critiquer sur le fond elle
permet en effet si toutefois les
conditions de travail sont convenables
d'assurer la permanence des procédures
d'améliorer l'information la
communication interne donc globalement
la qualité la traçabilité la perdre la
transparence évolutions que nous
écologistes réclamons dans d'autres
contextes nous ne sommes pourtant pas
naïf
il ne fait aucun doute que les gros
laboratoires on valoriser au maximum
l'accréditation aux yeux des pouvoirs
publics n'ont pas seulement pour des
raisons vertueuse mais parce qu'ils
savaient pouvoir l'assumer plus
facilement que d'autres
quoi qu'il en soit il est vrai que
l'accréditation des laboratoires dans un
premier temps soulevé le mécontentement
l'inquiétude de certains biologistes car
elle est onéreuse chronophage les
éloigne leur coeur de métier quand ils
ne sont pas en situation de délit
et cette tâche à un nouveau salarié mais
force est de constater que le processus
est aujourd'hui enclenché et là en effet
déjà été obtenus ou être en cours
d'obtention par un grand nombre
d'établissements
je rejoins de ce fait le constat fait
par le rapporteur en première lecture le
problème n'est pas l'accréditation en
elle même mais le rythme et les
modalités de sa mise en oeuvre et il
nous semble à ce sujet que le compromis
auquel nous sommes parvenus soient
équilibrés même si des inquiétudes
demeurent sur le cofrac comité français
d'accréditation cet organisme chargé
d'une mission de service public et
disposant d'un monopole national pour
son action pose en effet un problème
tant en raison de son manque
d'indépendance car les experts
biologique censé délivrer
l'accréditation sont souvent issus les
grands laboratoires qu'en raison des
tarifs élevés qui les appliquent
nous resterons donc vigilants sur cette
question et savons que nous ne serons
pas les seuls
c'est d'ailleurs une question qu'il faut
absolument revoir et rapidement et la
commission des affaires sociales a
d'ailleurs demandé un rapport à ce sujet
à la cour des comptes la
financiarisation et le second enjeu
important la réforme de la biologie
médicale
le fait que les fonds de pension ou
d'autres investisseurs spéculent ainsi
sur des établissements à vocation
sanitaire est en effet choquant et nous
étions beaucoup à partager l'objectif
d'y remédier en première lecture le
sénat avait d'ailleurs adopté un
amendement écologistes qui proposait que
l'ensemble des contrats et conventions
signés dans le cadre des sociétés
d'exercice libéral soit rendue publique
à la demande de l'un des détenteurs de
capital cet amendement visait
particulièrement les conventions extra
statutaire actuellement non communiquée
aux autorités qui permettent de
contourner l'esprit de la loi et
notamment les clauses dites
d'entraînement fréquemment introduite
dans lesdites conventions xtrata du ter
qui permettent notamment aux financiers
majoritaire d'obliger les minoritaires
en l'espèce les biologistes exerçant à
céder leurs parts en même temps que le
sorte que les premiers ne puissent avoir
leur mot à dire
en cas de volonté de cession des
financiers ou encore les clauses de type
buy or celles qui profitent également
aux financiers en contraignant un
actionnaire minoritaire soit racheté
l'intégralité des parts d majoritaire
soit avant de ses parts au majoritaire
au prix proposé par ces derniers
l'adoption de cet amendement au sénat
avec le soutien de notre rapporteur et à
une large majorité nous semblait une
avancée salutaire nous avons de ce fait
été déçus que l'assemblée le suppriment
purement et simplement cependant les
sénateurs ont fait entendre leur voix en
commission mixte paritaire nous sommes
parvenus à réinsérer dans le texte
aujourd'hui sur wii à notre suffrage la
disposition suivante je cite l'ensemble
des contrats et des conventions signés
dans le cadre des sociétés d'exercice
libéral et communiquée à l'ordre
compétents et toute convention clause
cachette alors inopposable il est clair
que la communication à l'ordre et moins
transparente que le fait de rendre
publiques ces conventions mais le
caractère alors inopposable des clauses
extra statutaire est une avancée en soi
qu'il faut souligner en conclusion le
groupe écologiste votera cette
proposition de loi
parce que nous partageons l'espoir
formulé par jacky le menn dans
l'introduction de ce rapport de voir ce
texte apporter sinon une solution
définitive du moins une solution durable
au problème de la biologie médicale mais
aussi parce que cette spécialité devenu
un élément central du parcours de soins
des patients la biologie médicale ne
doit donc plus souffrir de la de la
crispation et des turpitudes dans
lesquelles elle est plongée depuis
maintenant plusieurs années
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à catherine génisson pour
le groupe socialiste
oui
madame la présidente madame la ministre
alors même que la biologie médicale
française n'avait pas bénéficié de
réformes structurantes depuis près de 40
ans vous l'avez rappelé madame la
ministre
après quelques péripéties législatives
que je ne rappelle pas en soutenant les
résultats des travaux de notre
commission mixte paritaire nous avons
aujourd'hui la possibilité même si nous
sommes en réunion relativement intime et
j'ai envie de dire de donner un cadre
juridique clair à cette spécialité
médicale qui participent à 60% des
diagnostics médicaux et qui participe de
la qualité de notre système de santé
je souhaite remercier chaleureusement
notre rapporteur jacky le menn dont nous
avons pu apprécier la détermination et
le sens de l'écouté et je cet acte est
les travaux de la commission des
affaires sociales pour dire qu'ils se
sont déroulées avec la volonté partagée
par tous de définir la biologie médicale
française de demain biologie médicale
française qui s'est caractérisé par un
nombre important de biologistes ses
ennemis pour 100000 habitants contre 5,8
en moyenne dans les états membres de
l'union européenne et qui est également
constitué un nombre important de
structures de proximité qu'il convient
de préserver
aujourd'hui le défi que nous avons à
relever est double vous l'avez dit
madame le ministre c'est celui de la
qualité et celui de l'efficience à
l'exigence de qualité nous avons apporté
la réponse de l'accréditation qui doit
assurer fiabilité et qualité des examens
certains biologistes s'inquiète de la
lourdeur de la complexité de cette
proposition et prône une procédure à
double voie serait créé et
interrogations et doutes sur les
laboratoires non accrédités
l'accréditation progressive pour arriver
à 100 % en 10 or 2020 est une bonne
adaptation du dispositif nombre de
biologistes s'inquiètent aussi du coût
de cette accréditation de la
responsabilité du cofrac
félicitons-nous madame la ministre de la
proposition que vous avez cautionné de
faire expertiser par la cour des comptes
les prestations du cofrac je crois que
c'est un vrai sujet et au niveau de
notre commission des affaires sociales
ça a été dit par tous en fête seront
très vigilants sur cette question là car
je crois que c'est vraiment une vraie
question
en effet le coup de propre peu sollicité
par le cofrac est élevé et reconnaissons
que cela peut mettre en difficulté un
certain nombre de laboratoires
nous avons eu aussi de longs débats et
qui se poursuivent d'ailleurs ce soir
sur le sujet de rétablissement de
l'article 6 par la commission mixte
paritaire
après avoir beaucoup hésité à titre
personnel il me semble souhaitable de
permettre à des médecins ou de
pharmacien d'exercer en milieu
hospitalier universitaire la biologie
médicale sans être titulaires de ce
diplôme et je sais pouvoir compter sur
votre vigilance fadam la ministre pour
que cette disposition favorable à la
recherche et souhaitons ce et nous
devons soutenir notre recherche ne
pénalise pas les étudiants qui se
destinent à l'exercice de la spécialité
de biologie médicale je pense qu'il
faudra être là aussi vigilant mais je
sais pouvoir compter sur vous madame la
ministre
à la question de l'efficience nous avons
répondu par la mise en place de
garde-fous devons contrecarrer les abus
de la finance financiarisation l'article
8 répond à cette à cet objet bien
évidemment je pense que les dispositions
de cet article
8 ne sont pas parfaites non moi je pense
qu'elle apporte à progrès très sensible
au sujet de la lutte contre la
financiarisation et nous avions été
majoritaires au sénat a souhaité fixer
un seuil minimal de détention du capital
social pour chaque biologiste exerçant
sein d'une société d'exercice libéral
vous nous indiquez madame la ministre
que ce dispositif sera semble
difficilement compatible avec le droit
communautaire
aussi c'est avec regret que nous vous
suivrons dans votre volonté de supprimer
ces dispositions car vraiment nous ne
voulons pas compromettre l'application
en fin de ce texte après ces quelques
observations
fiers de donner à la biologie médicale à
statut juridique que nous voulons
efficient le groupe socialiste votera ce
texte
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je rappelle qu'en
application de l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement le sénat étant appelés à se
prononcer après l'assemblée nationale
sur le texte élaboré par la cmp
il se prononce par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte en ne retenant que
les amendements présentés ou acceptés
par le gouvernement
en l'occurrence il y a un seul
amendement du gouvernement
je vous demande à la ministre vien
vouloir présenter oui merci madame la
présidente très rapidement puisque j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire dans mon
intervention liminaire et il s'agit de
supprimer les harkis les alinéas 7 8 et
9 de l'article 8 du projet de la
proposition de loi ces dispositions ont
été introduites à l'occasion de la cmp
comme cela a été rappelé par plusieurs
intervenants ces dispositions pour
objectif de fixer un seuil minimal de
détention du capital social pour chaque
biologiste médical exerçant au sein
d'une société à exercice libéral
ce seuil serait fixée par décret en
conseil d'état et l'ensemble des
laboratoires devraient s'y conformer
dans un délai d'un an à compter de la
publication de la loi
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire ce
mécanisme pose plusieurs difficultés la
première est que ces dispositions
semblent contraires au droit européen ce
qui à un moment où
disons les dispositions relatives à
l'exercice de la biologie médicale en
france font l'objet d'un examen
particulièrement attentif par la
commission européenne serait de nature à
fragiliser notre dispositif
par ailleurs il est probable que
l'introduction d'un seuil aboutirait
l'objectif contraire ou à l'effet
contraire de l'objectif recherché c'est
à dire qu'il aboutirait à évincer des
jeunes biologistes qui souhaitent
pouvoir s'investir dans cette profession
en raison des difficultés financières
qui leur seraient ainsi imposé et enfin
je veux dire que ce dispositif
apparaîtrait comme un dispositif de
contraintes supplémentaires pour
l'ensemble de l'exercice de la
profession pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons le gouvernement soit être la
suppression des alinéas qui ont été
introduits par la cmp à l'article 8 donc
les alinéas 7,8 et merci madame la
ministre
le vote est réservé à la vie la
commission le rapporteur sur cet
amendement présenté par le gouvernement
en début d'après midi a donné un avis
favorable à cet amendement du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le rapporteur le vote est
réservé sur cet amendement conformément
à l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement je
vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi dans la rédaction
résultant du texte proposé par la
commission mixte paritaire
modifié par l'amendement du gouvernement
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
à ce stade je n'en vois pas
je mets donc aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi portant réforme de la
biologie médicale dans la rédaction
résultant du texte proposé par la
commission mixte paritaire modifié par
l'amendement du gouvernement
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par la commission des affaires
sociales sur le texte est mort et est
élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire modifié par l'amendement du
gouvernement
il va être procédé un scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instant
le scrutin est ouvert
ja troublé
le scrutin est clos plus personne ne
demande à voter le scrutin est clos
j'invite les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 127 sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
portant réforme de la biologie médicale
dans la rédaction du texte proposé par
la cmp modifié par un moment du
gouvernement nombre de votants 346
nombre de suffrages exprimés 210 pour
l'adoption 170 contre 40
le sénat a adopté définitivement
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
portant réforme de la biologie médicale
voilà pour cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir elle est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à tous
et moi je veux ici vous dire que je
viens sans doute de vivre la journée la
plus importante de ma vie politique
est ce ce jour là que françois hollande
a vraiment eu l'impression de devenir
président en tout cas c'est en décidant
de faire la guerre qu'un président
exerce la suprématie de son pouvoir
alors comment françois hollande parle
king de la guerre qu'il s'agisse du mali
ou de sa volonté d'intervenir en syrie
comment justifient la nécessité de ses
interventions et s'inscrit-il en rupture
par rapport à ses prédécesseurs
cette semaine des as bio en tout bien
tout honneur françois hollande ou chefs
de guerre disait beyond et demain à
18h15 sur public sénat